i'm the cto at hex if you haven't used
text yet we are a collaborative data
workspace for teams um and among
many delightful features that we've
built one of the main ones is a notebook
and i want to talk a little bit today
about how we are kind of pushing the
boundaries of the traditional notebook
paradigm which both enables really
powerful new workflows while kind of
keeping the interface that we all know
and love today so
i'm gonna get the clicker here cool
um i know you all have opted into this
talk so i'm assuming that most of you
have used notebooks and have potentially
fairly strong feelings about them one
way or the other they can be a bit of a
divisive topic so let's just see who we
have in the audience today who loves
notebooks i use notebooks for like
everything like word processing data
engineering got one in the front got a
couple in the front here um some people
with like maybe more mixed feelings
about notebooks yeah lots of you um
and you know you'll make me use a
notebook over like my cold dead body
all right none of those good cool we
like notebooks at hex
and then i assume you all kind of know
what notebooks are
so yeah so i'm not going to spend a lot
of time trying to pitch you on notebooks
and why you should use them or shouldn't
use them there's probably too many sort
of twitter hot takes on that subject
already
but i'm going to give you a little bit
of background on how we're thinking
about notebooks and then why we felt
like reactivity was the right thing to
build so
starting off way way back all the way
back so far back in the 1980s
donald knuth pioneered this concept of
literate programming this is a version
of programming where you interleave
the code
the outputs of the code and
narrative around around around that code
all in the same place and this
immediately took off it was a big hit
particularly in data disciplines
scientific disciplines and so just a few
years later you start to see tools
popping up around this the most famous
being mathematica
fast forward to today and notebooks are
everywhere people use notebooks for
everything under the sun you have your
workhorses like jupiter
but you see them in data engineering you
even see sort of more software
development-centric notebooks even so
observable.js is an example of this
and
why why does this happen why is notebook
so sticky and cool so in addition to
kind of the literate programming that i
was just talking about
data analytics is just highly iterative
and exploratory by nature and the nature
of a notebook to have these small
modular chunks of code that you kind of
run individually you can iterate on and
you know work really quickly on these
pieces of code just made this workflow
so much smoother and faster
okay so that's notebooks that's why
notebooks are great
but as we saw from the room i'm sure
you're all aware notebooks have some
problems this is a
screenshot here from the
famous or perhaps uh infamous joel
groostalk from jupitercon in 2018.
i don't like notebooks he goes through
many
many reasons why notebooks are actually
a completely terrible tool for
development
and the list is extensive i'm not going
to go through all of them here but i do
find that a lot of them boil down to
actually a simple fundamental problem
and this problem is so pervasive that
internally at hex we've actually given
it a name and we call it the state
problem
the simplest version of the state
problem is kind of the following here's
a really complicated notebook you've
been working on it for a really long
time
some really interesting analysis here
and then you go to run
the last cell
so what is this print
have any volunteers from the audience
exactly this is a trick question there
is literally no way to know what this is
gonna print it could print one it could
print two it could print a hundred
thousand
because
the this statement does not depend on
anything that you currently see in a
notebook it actually depends on the
contents of the memory that the notebook
is running on so if you had if this cell
had originally said a equals 15 you go
and run that cell a is now 15 in memory
you change it to b2 and now there's no
record anywhere of what that actual
value is
and the fundamental reason for this is
because notebooks are built around a
programming paradigm called imperative
programming and all that means is that
in imperative programming you have a
list of sequential statements you run
them in order and they update a shared
mutable state
this should sound very familiar because
most programming is in fact imperative
programming and so in the case of a
notebook statements are just cells
and then the shared memory in this case
is actually often referred to as the
kernel but that is really just a fancy
python process running under the hood
all right downstream effects of
imperative programming models so
one of the biggest things about
notebooks is that it's very very
difficult to understand what they are
going to do just from reading them
because of this problem that we just
described and that's true for your own
notebook let alone coming into a
notebook that you don't really
understand
reproducibility really really important
um in data disciplines um but
because of the way that we're operating
on this mutable state that we can't
really see um you can end up with these
kind of really subtle bugs that make it
really hard to get um the same results
without just like constantly restarting
your notebook and running everything
from scratch but when you do that which
is actually a
something that we adopted at hex here we
did this a lot
um
that's actually just really wasteful and
and not performant because even if
you're just sort of moving like a small
filter or something on a chart you have
to rerun the whole whole big notebook
which which could be hundreds of cells
it gets worse
um
a lot of you in the audience who've
worked with notebooks probably have
workarounds you have tools you have
jupyter extensions you have all of these
things to try to make this workflow
better but think about all of the other
people in your organization who really
want to work with data they want to ask
questions of the data and they come in
to a notebook as their first experience
with that this can be super intimidating
it can often turn people off entirely so
not only is it making your job harder
now you also have to do everybody else's
work as well because they can't actually
interact with the data in a sensible way
so where does that leave us
notebooks are really great it's for
iterative development but it turns out
that all of the features of notebooks
that make them so great for this are
exactly the same features that get you
into trouble when you're trying to sort
of productionize and and build more
complexity and we ran into this a lot at
hex especially once we started
introducing more heavyweight sql
features because we started getting this
big influx of users who didn't even know
what jupiter was they'd never they loved
the notebook ui but they'd never had any
experience dealing with the messiness of
kernel state and so our most frequent
support
response to questions
was
have you tried restarting and running
the notebook from scratch and that fixed
like 80 of the problems but it was
really pervasive and we banged our head
against this for
a really long time we tried a lot of
stuff we ran a bunch of experiments
on um
different ways that you could model
state in a notebook and some of them
were just as complicated as the original
notebook state but we did settle on one
approach that ended up being both
very intuitive to users and also like
really solve this sort of
reproducibility and interpretability
problem
so
for this approach we drew on a different
programming paradigm called reactive
programming which again i'm sure some of
you in the audience are kind of familiar
with this but just to get everybody on
the same page i wanted to give a quick
definition so reactive programming
is
well if you look at wikipedia it says
it's a programming paradigm oriented
around data flows and the propagation of
change
um
that's not particularly helpful if
you're actually trying to write a
program with it so in practice what this
usually means is you actually have a set
of reactive objects and these objects
maintain their dependencies up and down
stream and so when the value of one of
those objects changed changes it can
propagate throughout the graph
automatically
why would you use this so it has a lot
of really nice properties so you know
we're already talking about state
reactive programs have state consistency
automatically because every change gets
automatically propagated
performance because you are explicitly
maintaining dependencies in a lot of
cases you don't need to just rerun
everything just in case you can actually
only rerun the things that
actually need to be updated
and then also it has some nice
abstractions for asynchronous and
concurrent workflows which are really
really common in data products
this is just a quick example here of a
reactive program or imperative program
on the right here to reactive program on
the left so in an imperative program all
we're doing is we're sort of assigning
these variables and then when we get to
here this c we look up a it's 4 we look
at b it's 10 we assign c the value of 14
in memory and where that has come from
is completely lost so when we change a c
is no longer c is not updated it's still
the old value
um by contrast in the reactive side
we actually do maintain references here
to a and b and we know that that's how c
is being computed so when we update a we
actually automatically recompute c to
take into account the new value of a
normally you'd probably be using like a
library or language
feature for this so it would look a
little bit different but i kind of left
that out for ease of comparison here
this distinction might seem a little
esoteric
until you realize that i'm sure
everybody
in this room and anyone who's ever
worked with data has used reactive
programming before
and that's because of course the most
famous example of reactive programming
is a spreadsheet
ahead of their time um
so when you're defining a formula in a
spreadsheet you're defining a reactive
node you're defining the dependencies in
the graph
and
you know when it when the dependencies
change it updates automatically
obviously people love this
people love spreadsheets
they're never in an inconsistent state
because things are propagating
automatically and it's easy to trace
back the current value of a cell
by just looking at the dependencies in
the formula excel even has a feature for
this so this is the trace precedence
feature which i learned about from barry
our resident excel master
and uh this shows you
not only the data flow but it also shows
you another property of all reactive
programs which is that they are dags
again don't need to explain dags to this
audience they've kind of proliferated in
the data space and there's a reason for
this which is that they're really easy
to understand to debug and to there's
really no confusion about the order in
which things are being run
cool
it's a lot of intro but at this point
you've probably guessed what we built
which is a fully dag-based reactive
execution model for notebooks
and what this means is that when you're
editing the code in the notebook we are
actually live updating the dependency
graph we're generating it we're live
updating it on top of
you know sort of the traditional cell
model
and then when you run a cell we
automatically look at all the cells up
and down stream that need to be rerun
and we rerun those for you
so we found that this really elegantly
solves all of the problems that we
talked about earlier so
interpretability and reproducibility
because the notebook is no longer ever
in an inconsistent state with memory all
of these problems just kind of go away
and then for performance as i mentioned
earlier with the dag we actually can
only you know we can just rerun the
cells that need updating and not have to
worry about restarting and re-running
everything from scratch
cool so just to give you a quick sense
for what we built here this is hex
and this video should play automatically
in just a second
potentially i have to click on it
technical difficulties here
do you know how to play the video in the
in the deck
it's uh okay let's try that
next slide
nope that is the other side
i promised this was actually a video um
and not just a screenshot of the product
can i do that
oh i think i know what happened um did
we convert this to powerpoint out of
google slides
because this is we're running a
powerpoint here um that's
might have gotten lost in the transfer
there um okay cool um well let's go back
into presentation mode then um
had to happen at some point um
cool so basically
we're gonna skip the demo but what you
will see here in this demo or what you
would have seen um is that when you go
into reactive mode essentially you have
you know we have sort of input
parameters that we built into hex when
you change you can
write sql queries based on them when you
change that
automatically flows to the graph and
then we have this really nice graph ui
which i wish you could see because it's
very beautiful um that shows you how all
of the cells are re-running
so cool let's uh move on and talk a
little bit about how we built this so
actually you get a nice screenshot here
of this is what the graph ui actually
looks like which is pretty cool so yeah
we have some you know input ui
parameters here and then all of the
downstream uh data from that
so yeah so under the hood how did we
actually compute this so
we
first the dag how do we create a dag so
we export a few different mappings here
um so
you know you could you could there's a
variety of different ways that you can
create a dag out of a notebook we ended
up settling on one that's uh pretty
simple which is just that cells are the
nodes it's worth noting that this means
that reactivity doesn't work kind of
within
a node within a cell rather only between
nodes but we when we kind of tested it
out we felt like that was a reasonable
trade-off for a simpler more
understandable and legible graph
and then the edges so what we do for for
edges in the graph is we actually first
look for variable assignments so these
are places in the graph or or in the
notebook where we are assigning a very a
variable a value and then we look for
references to those variables and we
generate a directed edge from every
assignment to every reference of that
same variable
so to answer the obvious question here
how do we do that um yes we are parsing
the code directly and we are parsing it
live as you're editing the notebook this
is actually fortunately pretty well
understood in kind of the programming
languages and compilers community and
there's like a whole other talk that you
could do about how you actually do this
but for the purposes of this
transformation the only concept that we
actually really need is the abstract
syntax tree and python is really nice
because python actually has a library
for generating this data structure
automatically for you and so all we're
doing here
is generating a semantic representation
of
what the code is supposed to do before
we actually go and run it if you were a
python interpreter or a compiler you
would then actually go run the code for
us we actually just look at this tree
and as i said before we were looking for
assignments and we were looking for
references which you can see quite
clearly here
we have the assignments right here and
these assign nodes and then the
references kind of down here in in the
name nodes
cool so we have a graph
we can create a graph from a notebook
we're all done right good
there's actually a couple couple issues
with the approach
that i just described and i'm wondering
if people have spotted the problems
okay no volunteers i got one
it's actually a really good question
and that's something that i can talk
about in sort of like the usability
section later um
but actually the biggest problem here is
that
this
does not generate a dag
uh you can have cycles
there's no restriction on notebooks um
that doesn't you know disallows this and
so if you just naively try to do the
transformation i just described you can
end up with a cycle between cells
and then the other big problem is that
sibling nodes integra you can have
sibling nodes in the graph where the
ordering actually really matters
and and the dags just have no opinion on
which way to run these nodes so if you
you could potentially rerun it and get
different results every time
fortunately there's actually a fairly
simple and elegant solution to this
which is that we combine sort of the
traditional linearity of notebooks with
the dag structure
to basically be a tiebreaker so in the
case of a cycle all we do is we remove
sort of the backwards edge and then it's
nice and in the case of sibling nodes we
strictly order them based on the order
that they appear in the notebook
may not be what you wanted sometimes
but it does produce consistent ordering
and actually we've had this in
production for
months with thousands of people pressure
testing it and what we found is that
actually like the vast majority of the
time this is this is a really good
heuristic even though you can like maybe
come up with some edge cases where it's
not precisely what you were expecting
okay so at this point i'm going to put
it all together
i'm
talking about how we actually
implemented this on top of ipython
the last concept that i need to
introduce here in order to like fully uh
flush this out is the idea of staleness
this is really really straightforward
it's just as you know cells that are
currently out of sync with the notebooks
so a cell is stale
if it hasn't been run yet in this kernel
session so if you've restarted the
kernel and the cell hasn't been run it's
out of sync with the memory um if an
upstream cell has been edited obviously
the cell is no longer no longer up to
date
interestingly if an upstream cell has
been run all of its downstream cells are
also stale because you know cells may
not produce the same result every time
think about randomness or you know data
just updating
and then lastly if any upstream cell of
this cell has itself become stale we
have to propagate that all the way
through
so with that um
the algorithm
so in each edit
we update we run each cell through the
asd and we compute sort of these inputs
and output variables as we call them in
hex
then we recompute the dag based on that
so then we traverse all of the cells
upstream and downstream and it's worth
noting that sometimes upstream cells
need to be rerun as well as downstream
cells
upstream if anything's up to date filter
that out downstream we mark everything
as stale
and then we cue all of these cell runs
into the kernel sort of in order in the
in the notebook order automatically and
we're just running these in the regular
ipython kernel and then we mark each
cell as up to date after it runs
successfully
you mentioned usability earlier we did
have to do a bunch of work on the
usability side it was actually probably
one of the hardest things that we that
we did um as part of this whole project
um and there was a few main things that
we implemented on the usability front so
one is you'll it's really common for
notebooks to have
the first cell here um
be
just a bunch of import statements
um
and
that me and so this rarely ever changes
but it also has a like creates
dependencies on literally every other
cell in the in the notebook which when
you're sort of thinking about this dag
ui can create a lot of clutter so we
actually hide import edges by default
another one is um we also by default
hide cells with no links these are often
just markdown cells which are really
important for the narrative but much
less important for the data flow of the
notebook
and then lastly if there's two edges
between two nodes we merge them into a
single edge just to kind of reduce
clutter
i mean that's pretty much it end to end
um i've left out a ton of stuff
obviously on the implementation side you
know on the usability i mentioned
usability testing and making sure that
it was understandable to people kind of
coming in and they actually could really
operate with it and figure out what was
going on there was a big old migration
that we had to do to get all the
notebooks in the new format but overall
this has been just
a phenomenally successful project i
think i mean it's one of the things that
i hear a lot about when people start
using hex they're like
i'm just never going back to the old way
and
that for me personally i built a lot of
data products and i don't know hearing
hearing things like that just means that
i'm doing my job right i think
lots of stuff we could do in the future
i'm really excited sort of about the
future of where we can take notebook
compute
you could talk about like i don't know
better isolation between cells doing
things with lambdas
caching other parallelization and
performance improvements there's really
just a whole universe of stuff that this
opens up and we're going to continue to
explore that at hex and see what we can
see what we can build for you all
so yeah um
there we go and of course i would be
completely remiss if i did not mention
the incredibly talented team that put
all this together for you
um i mean i'm standing up here and i get
to take all the credit but actually it
was these really really wonderful folks
um who did a lot of sort of the design
and the inventing and all the like work
of making it a reality and i personally
couldn't be more thrilled to work with
this incredible group of engineers
and if you too are interested in working
on this stuff i feel obligated to
mention that we are hiring for a bunch
of different roles and you can come find
me at the conference if you want to talk
more about that
so yeah that's it for me thanks for all
coming
[Applause]